all right Lords of gaming dotnet I'll or
podcast one of the most anticipated
titles Mortal Kombat 11 it looks like we
got about 10 selectable character
scorpions in the building we got
variations Johnny Cage is the opponent
looking very retro for oh look at those
suits those suits are awesome
oh he's cracking the neck he's ready
he's right I think you're gonna for a
long night MJ is cracking the neck is
ready we're gonna get it on random
select man the trailer for this thing
look fantastic
ed boning the crew Mortal Kombat looks
revisited and better than ever so here
we go and the og get over here King one
thing about Mortal Kombat love the
personal conversations with each
character let's go classic matchup
scorpion versus Johnny Cage Johnny Cage
is leather jacket is very sparkling
right now
okay okay okay
[Music]
getting it in no one's that a special
move yet I'm gonna look at CERN there we
go all x-ray time x-rays I'm vicious
yeah the fatal blows are amazing here we
go hmm Johnny came to come back even
though he had a sigh in his face but he
was able to recover just a scratch
there's nothing to a movie star looking
like damage over time on the bodies
there which is pretty cool oh by mental
cactus cactus work oh here comes the
x-ray well that's okay x-ray juggle nice
least I'll get over here oh I'm done the
min just punched his head straight off
bunching johnnycakes bunch of guys head
straight off it's all good man that was
fantastic man awesome
gotta love it man